Welcome back to human emotion.
So today we're going to discuss both love
as well as sex and ask ourselves just
how does a promotion play a role
here? Um, so for example, um,
we'll ask the question in some ways like
what is love and sex got to do with it?
So exactly to what extent does emotion
shape the love we feel towards others as
well as our patterns of
sexual desire and arousal.
So we're gonna follow this road map today.
We'll start by talking
about love moving to desire,
moving to some really controversial and
provocative research on sexual arousal
followed by takeaway questions and an
expert interview with Dr. Michael Bailey.
So let's start with love.
So romantic love.
What is it in the first place?
So we know romantic love is something
that we all have some sense of.
We've read about and many of
us one day hope to experience.
So let me share a few features about
what psychologists and people who study
him. Human emotion think
romantic love actually is.
So we think of romantic love as something
that underlies pair bonding between
partners and that it's thought to
help foster long term commitment,
um, and also help people stay together
in terms of fostering mutual goals.
Um, ultimately romantic love really seems
to be about keeping people together so
that they can rear offspring
over the longterm course. Okay.
So that doesn't sound
very romantic at all. Um,
what else does romantic
love associated with? Well,
we also know that it's associated with
the release of a neuropeptide you may
have heard of called oxytocin.
So this has been colloquially,
colloquially referred to as the love
hormone and that it's this hormone that's
thought to make us feel romantic love
and feel sort of attached and bonded with
another romantic partner.
And what I think is really fun is to
look at what are the behavioral displays
that people show when they're
feeling in love and say,
you see this funny combination of a head
tilt smile and making this very subtle
kind of, uh, you know, coy eye contact.
So what does this look like?
So these are images,
courtesy of Dacher Keltner who's
been studying these displays of love.
And here you can see exactly that. So you
find that the head gets tilt slightly.
People think it's a way of sort of
displaying your vulnerability to another
partner.
You see this kind of subtle smile
and you also see eye contact.
So many of you might remember times in
which maybe you were in class when you
were young, high school, college or
someone gave you that special look.
And what that special look really was
is the head tilting, looking at you,
making eye contact and smiling. So
that's thought to be our sort of, um,
you know, expressions or
displays of lab 11, the face.
Okay.
And what do we think about
what romantic love is?
So Sternberg has a theory of love and
this theory of love had three components.
The first component was intimacy.
So he talked about this
as a feeling of closeness,
connecting and connectedness and bonding.
So this is related to sharing information
with this person that you wouldn't
normally share with other people.
That's the first component of love.
The second was passion.
So he talked about this
notion of having desire,
you need to have physical attraction,
desire,
and sort of the proclivity to want to
have sex with the other person. Right?
And the third is this idea
of longterm commitment.
So this is the decision that one
is in this loving relationship.
They're willing to label
it as a relationship, uh,
which I know can be an issue for
many kinds of relationships that,
that wanting to commit and say,
I am in this relationship with you and
to maintain this relationship over time.
So intimacy,
passion,
and commitment are the three components
of love according to Sternberg.
And he noted that you need to have all
three components in order to truly have
romantic love. So what happens then if
you are missing some of these components,
if you have some but not all.
So he walked through several different
categories of different kinds of love,
like feelings, um, when you're missing
one or more of these components.
But keep in mind, these are no longer
romantic love if you don't have all three.
So what does it look like if you
have different combinations of them?
So first he would say there's
something called non love.
So this is where you have none of the
three components. You don't have intimacy,
you don't have passion, you don't have
commitment, there's no love going on their
liking. So we've heard people
say, I really like you.
I just don't love you.
So what this is thought to be of
as having this sense of intimacy,
only feeling connected with the person
but not having the passion, the desire,
and not really wanting to maintain
that long term commitment.
So these are more what we think of as,
you know,
I just want to be your
friend or casual friendships.
Then there's infatuation.
So here you have the passion,
you have the desire,
but you just don't feel
that close connection and
you're not really interested
in staying with them, uh, in the long run.
So people talk about this
as love at first sight. Um,
that this is really more about sort of,
uh,
your sort of system of desire and
sexual arousal and nothing more.
And then there's empty love.
So this is this sense of commitment.
So you're in it for the long
run to stay with this person,
but you no longer are
feeling intimacy or passion.
This can often be a sad but final stage
of longterm relationships that seem to
have just kind of fizzled out or gone
bad. So for example, it's, you know,
better to just stay together for
the kids' sake or for sort of social
appearances.
Um,
this empty love is often the first
stage of a relationship and arranged
marriages.
Um,
which is interesting because later on
they don't have a higher rate of ending in
divorce,
but it's also seen as the final stage
often before couples will often divorce or
split up.
So here you're committed to the person,
but you're missing some of the two key
ingredients of intimacy and passion.
There's also this sense
of um, romantic love. So,
um, what's interesting here, this is sort
of what we see in story tales, right?
Think of like Romeo and Juliet,
right?
So here you have the intimacy,
you have the passion,
but for different reasons you're unable
to make that commitment to be with them
long term. Um, some people
also think of things like,
I'm like the titanic as well.
Then there's companionate love,
right? So this is what you feel for like
a really good, really close best friend.
So you have the sense of intimacy and
closeness. You have the commitment,
you want to stay being close
to them for a very long time,
but there's just no sexual desire arousal.
Um,
so that's companionate love,
right?
Then there's fatuous love.
So here you have passion and
commitment, right? You have the,
the desire sexually,
you want to stay with them,
but you don't have that sort of
deeper psychological connection.
So you're only really committed
to each other for sex.
So the examples that are often talked
about or these kind of whirlwind
courtships,
um,
some people think of like Tom
Cruise and Katie Holmes or you know,
Britney Spears in her
mini fatuous love affairs.
And then finally there's
this idea of consummate love.
So here you really have all
three components of love.
And Sternberg would say this is
truly the sort of full deal of love.
This is the real thing when you have
all three together at the same time.
Um, and if you'd like to
see more about this, um,
Sternberg's theory of love was also
talked about in an open Yale course taught
by professor Paul Bloom,
um,
where there's a guest lecture by Peter
Saliday here at Yale University on
evolution, emotion and reason
where he talked about love.
So if you want to hear more about this,
you can also go to the website below and
watch a really provocative and engaging
lecture on this topic further.
So we've talked about love,
but what about desire? We've
hinted that it's part of, you know,
Sternberg's theory of love,
but what is desire really?
So here what I have side by side is
romantic love and the different components
we just talked about and pitting
this against sexual desire.
So romantic love is really thought to be
fostering this commitment role to stay
with someone in order to help
rear offspring and foster alarm,
longterm commitment.
By contrast,
sexual desire has which just called an
initiation role to kind of initiate this
kind of repetitive or approach behavior
to essentially go and meet with,
with a potential, you know, partner.
So really what it's focused on
is promoting sexual behavior,
getting close to the person.
So proximity seeking and just
making physical contact. Um,
it's associated with releasing different
gonadal kind of estrogen and androgen
hormones, which are thought
of as the sexual hormones.
And it has a very different kind
of diff behavioral display too,
which is pretty funny.
So when people are feeling sexual desire,
they do things like lip puckers,
they a lick their lips,
they kind of turn their head away and
they make this kind of subtle coy eye
contact.
So they'll,
they'll look at eye contact just
briefly for one or two seconds,
that kind of flirtatious quick glance.
And they'll do what's called a coy smile.
So, um, I'll show you
what this looks like.
This is also an image
courtesy of Dacher Keltner.
This is what is thought
to be a display of desire.
Now think about what we showed earlier,
which were the displays of love here.
What you see as this kind
of coy kind of head tilts,
the smile and the eye
contact is very brief.
It's just this kind of subtle looking
back and looking forward very quickly.
And this is thought to be a
signal that you should pick up at.
That person is really interested in you
and really wants to get close to use
actually. Um, so that's the
sort of display of desire.
What we see here,
it's really interesting is that some
research points to some potential gender
differences in the way they
signal or cue desire to a partner.
So this is a really fun study.
Researchers actually spent their time,
hundreds of hours in bars and single bars
and what they would do is study these
brief kind of four to five second bursts
of behaviors between a single women and
single men.
And actually found that the way that
they sort of transmit their feelings of
desire look quite different. Okay,
so you get an a single's bar,
you're a researcher, and you're just
watching what's happening around you.
And here's what they found. So what a
women do when they want to signal desire,
they do this funny sort
of, um, theatrical, uh,
kind of a display of, of different things
that include, they arch their back,
you know, they kind of sway their
hips, they, they flip their hair. Um,
it's on,
and this,
what this is thought to two is almost
exemplify this kind of hourglass figure of
the female body and sort of exaggerate
these feminine kind of physiological
characteristics. Um, by contrast,
men do something very different when
they're trying to signal a desire or
interest in a sexual partner. They do
things, for example, as you can see here,
like amplifying their size and their
sort of research resource holding
potential. So they kind of rock
back and forth on their heels.
They roll their shoulders,
they raise their arms and make
these exaggerated gestures.
So kind of trying to
exemplify their physical size,
status and resources. Um,
so it's really fascinating.
Next time you go to a singles bar to
just watch the way that men and women
behave differently when they're trying
to sort of signal their sexual desire.
And try to gain sexual attention
from another partner. Um,
so when we think of
sexual attraction then,
what are the kind of core components?
So there's,
I think you can think of two different
groups or factors that are associated
with sexual attraction. The first one
is what's thought of as the big three.
So proximity,
similarity and familiarity.
So these are things that
breeds sexual attraction,
being close to someone having some
similarity, which is actually co,
it's sort of counter to this
idea that opposites attract.
They actually don't attract very much
at all. It's more this notion that,
you know, birds of a feather flock
together and also familiarity.
So sort of being around someone you know
over time increases sexual attraction.
So you often see, you know,
sexual relationships between
coworkers, office mates,
and this has a lot to do with the
familiarity. You're just surround them,
you know,
over frequent or prolonged period of time.
Other factors that are thought to
sort of promote sexual attraction.
And the second group or what I call
the remaining four are the following.
So the first one is competence.
So, not surprisingly,
we like people who seem to be
competent. Um, but really important.
We don't want them to be perfect and in
fact we are more sexually attracted to
people who are competent,
but those who occasionally blunder.
So maybe they sort of, you know,
trip and fall or make like a verbal,
you know,
[inaudible] we actually find that to be
something that makes us more attracted
to them. So if you want to sort of, when
someone's attention, um, definitely,
you know,
look competent to them,
but it's okay to make an occasional
stumble or fall that this actually,
um, makes you more desirable in
their eyes. Not surprisingly,
physical attractiveness has a great
impact on the extent to which we find
ourselves sexually drawn towards someone.
Then there's this idea of gain loss.
So we are attracted to those whose
regard for us increases or gains momentum
over time.
So it's in a sense you don't want to
start right at the beginning was someone
you know at their maximum
level of interest in you,
but you see more attracted to people
who sort of over time seems to,
uh, seem to be more and more interested
in interested in you and who's regard for
you kind of increases and over time.
So you don't want to sort of put
all your cards out right away,
but you want to sort of let it gradually
build up and escalate over time.
And this is a really interesting one.
Misattribution um, and this actually,
people often use this as advice for sort
of how to take someone on a first date.
So often, um, there's this theory
of misattribution of arousal.
So when you're around someone and let's
say you get physiologically aroused,
your heart starts racing. Um,
you know, you start sweating.
If you're around someone who
you might be sexually, uh,
as a sexual romantic partner,
you're likely to attribute that
physio physiological arousal to them.
So, for example, and the, as a result,
if you feel this physiological arousal
while you're around the person,
you read this as a cue of, Oh,
well I must be attracted to them.
So people will say that, you know, some
of the best first dates are taking your,
you know,
potential partner on a rollercoaster.
So some of that kind of
gets them physically charged
because they're more likely
to attribute that physiological arousal
not to the rollercoaster, but to you.
So you want to think about just how
you can get people to attribute their
arousal, uh, to you.
And so these are some of the seven
factors that are thought to promote sexual
attraction.
And again,
this is something that you can see
more of on this open Yale course at the
website below, uh, through a guest
lecture from Peter Saliday. Okay,
so let's now turn to sexual arousal
here.
What we're going to look at his work
by Dr. Michael Bailey from Northwestern
university,
um,
who looked at two different ways to
measure sexual arousal and looked at
differences between men and women who
were either heterosexual or homosexual.
And really looked at this question of
do patterns in sexual arousal really
differ across these groups?
So the first way that he measured sexual
arousal was just by using subjective
ratings. So this is something that
we're all familiar with and he had,
this is actually an image that he
loaned to me from his own work,
which was a lever here.
So where they would have the lever from
not at all arouse to extremely aroused
at the very top.
And this is something that people would
be moving sort of manually throughout
the task. Okay. He also
measured physiological arousal,
right? So we know that emotional responses
have both subjective and physiological
components. So he did this,
you measuring genital arousal,
both in females using a
vaginal plethysmograph,
which measures the amplitude of blood
flow to the vagina and with men,
what he called [inaudible]
mograph measuring the d,
The circumference of the penis
as a function of blood flow.
So this is actually what he used
in his lab. So this is for women,
this is the plethysmograph and this is
the one used for men in this study. Okay?
So he has people hooked up to
these two computers with these,
put these monographs with these rating
dials, and what does he have them do?
So here's the study that if he did
that of sexual arousal and it's quite
interesting and uh, has gained a lot
of attention, even some controversy.
So he brought participants into the lab.
Okay.
And the participants
were in four categories.
There were men and women who are
either heterosexual or homosexual.
So there were male, heterosexual,
Male, homosexual, female,
heterosexual and female homosexual.
And then what he had them do is
watch a series of evocative, uh,
sexually arousing film clips with all
kinds of different combinations that you
could possibly imagine of men and women
together are women and women's together
are women and men and see other doing
a variety of different kinds of sexual
acts. So it included things you
can see here as following, right?
So you had just all kinds of things to
appeal to, all different kinds of tastes.
Right.
And so what he wanted to do is to see
whether or not men and women really differ
in their patterns of sexual arousal when
watching these different film clips.
And so let's start with
the results for men.
So what did we see when they saw these
different film clips and they were
measuring both their subjective ratings
and their physiological response of
sexual arousal. It's
interesting. So, okay,
so what you have here is the
picture of the self report dial.
And you have three colors here.
You have the responses to
watching a male male film,
a female female film or
a male and female film.
So what they found was subjective
responses here is that men who prefer men.
So homosexual men show the greatest self
reported arousal when viewing male male
films. Okay? And over here on the right,
men who prefer women, so who self
identify as being heterosexual,
show the greatest,
um,
self reported arousal to female
female films followed by mail, mail,
films. Okay, so that's what they
showed for their subjective response.
What about physiological response?
So here what you're seeing,
and this is using that plethysmograph
that you can see here on the bottom right,
is that men who prefer men.
So homosexual men show the
greatest physical arousal
to the male male films and
purple that's the left graft.
And that men who prefer women.
So heterosexual men show the greatest
arousal again to these female female films
followed by male with female films.
So this is really consistent with
their self reported response. Okay.
So what uh,
this work has concluded is
that heterosexual men seem
to generally show greater
or more increased sexual
arousal to heterosexual stimuli,
which they define as both men
with women or women with women.
And that homosexual men show the greatest
kind of sexual response in terms of
their arousal to homosexual stimulators.
So men with men.
So he concludes that male sexual
arousal is really category specific.
So you're going to show more arousal to
the kind of stimuli that's specific to
your self identified sexual orientation.
Okay,
now we'll look at women.
It's an interesting and very
different pattern of results actually.
So here we're going to start with
self reported arousal. Again,
same layout that we had before.
So on the left,
what we see is that heterosexual women,
so women who have a
male preference report,
the greatest arousal for male female
films followed closely by female female
films. Um, on the right by contrast.
So these are homosexual women report
the greatest arousal by female female
films. Okay? When we get to
physiological or sort of genital arousal,
what we see something quite different.
So on the left we see that heterosexual
women exhibit equal sec sexual arousal
for any kind of film. It doesn't matter if
it's male, male, female, female, or male,
female. And when you look
at homosexual women, um,
what you see as the exhibit as somewhat
greater arousal to female female films,
but also seem to show similarly high
arousal across all other film types as
well.
So this is the interesting
kind of controversial part
of this research here is
that he concludes that female sexual
arousal is not category specific.
And he argues in this
paper by shivers that, ah,
that women's show more of what
he calls a bisexual pattern.
So women's sexual arousal is bisexual
regardless of their identified sexual
orientation,
that they show more physiological
arousal across a wide variety of stimuli.
And so he says this is particularly
true of the genital arousal or the
physiological responding. So,
um, what does this all mean?
Right? So what this is
suggested by this research by,
by the authors is that men and women's
sexuality May in fact be organized
differently.
And that Michael Bay,
these labs showed that
men's genital sexual arousal
patterns closely track their
set, identified sexual orientations,
whereas women's did not.
Um, so this is something that
will be really interesting
to speak with them about
when we have our experts
in emotion interview.
Cause it's something that's gained a lot
of attention and even some controversy
as to what it all means.
So what I want to move now to our
takeaway questions followed by the expert
interview Michael Bailey that I've been
referring to in his research thus far.
So our takeaway questions
today on this topic of love,
desire and sex RF follows first to how
is romantic love distinct from sexual
desire?
What are Sternberg's components
of romantic love? Um,
we talked about three of them and we also
talked about what it looked like when
some, but not all of those
components were precedent.
So you want to refresh yourself as to
what those different forms of love looked
like. And then finally what
we just talked about. Um,
and what I'd like you to do is try to
describe what these gender differentiated
patterns in sexual arousal were both for
subjective and physiological measures
of sexual arousal and to what extent
men and women seem to differ in their
patterns of sexual arousal.
And with that,
I will be turning now to our
highly anticipated expert
interview as part of the
experts in emotions series
with Dr. Michael Bailey. Um,
so Dr. Bailey is a professor of psychology
at Northwestern University and highly
regarded for his work on the
etiology of sexual orientation,
gender nonconformity,
the genetics of sexual orientation
and the sexual arousal response.
He's the author of the well known book,
the man who would be queen,
the science of gender bending
and transsexualism, which
was published in 2003.
And his work has received
widespread attention in the media,
including the Boston Globe,
Washington Post, CBS,
CBS News,
just to name a few.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with Dr. Michael Bailey.